what's up guys so we're talking more
about iphone 7 obviously because it's
really the only thing that i've been
careful talking about
my friends have just seen where's all of
your cooking videos and vlogs and
everything else
i don't know they'll be back once the
iphone's out some of the questions that
i've been getting from you guys is is
mostly concerns about how are you going
to listen to music while charging your
phone it's an issue it really really is
but there's solutions don't worry we'll
take a look at some of the cases that
apple has to offer we'll look at some
headphone options and then we're going
to dive in to amazon and see what
they've got i've yet to even click
through since the announcement to see if
they've added anything else some of it's
probably fake and not even real and
they're just labeling it iphone 7. so
i'm excited to see what we can see let's
first check out apple's site here so
clearly the first thing that apple is
pushing is the airpods not even
available yet so i tried to even order
them that night when i did the pre-order
for the iphone which was a complete
disaster please raise your hand or leave
me a comment in the comments below if
you guys did not have a hot mess of a
disaster trying to order at midnight it
happens every time you'd think
they'd have it figured out but i think
they actually do have it figured out and
they strategically make it so we can't
actually order it or maybe that's what
they want us to think and they actually
do have problems i'm not sure and of
course they're pushing their it's gross
headphones which we will not even
address them so the iphone 7 smart
battery case my sister had this she
liked it i have a lot of friends that
have this i would love to have one as
well but they don't make it for the
iphone 7 plus so please i made the
mistake of ordering this and not reading
i just got so excited the day that it
was launched back when they had it for
the iphone 6
and i failed to realize that oh it's a
little bit smaller than my current phone
so jenna had the iphone 6 small so she
used it for a really long time and is
basically just like their silicone cases
just with a little bump on it which is a
battery charger and it's cool because it
does connect through the lightning port
and it'll give you notifications right
on your home screen saying hey your case
is 100 full your phone is 90 full so
it'll kind of shut off and turn off when
you actually need it so that's kind of
cool here's one of the lightning iphone
docks which i have used in the past i
used to have one right next to my
nightstand also do have an audio out so
if you're having sort of that dilemma of
okay i want to charge my phone and
listen to music you can get one of these
where you can have an audio out so you
can connect that to speakers or
something like that so that's a super
simple solution if you want to plug in
your phone charge it and listen to music
this is not a mobile solution though
this is one of those i'm going to put
this on my desk and then plug it into a
speaker so this is definitely not
something that you want to take with you
on road trips or maybe on an airplane
not
really the best idea but it comes in a
bunch of different colors
to match your phone let's take a look at
some of their cases so i'm such a fan of
the silicon cases i have them in almost
every color not every color but my
favorite colors one of the huge updates
that i am so excited about is apple
finally fixed the biggest problem with
their white cases usually if you get a
white case you want it to be super slick
and really really just nice and white
but they had this
huge
black apple logo on the back like this
is crazy make it a little bit lighter so
i'm very appreciative that apple
listened to probably a lot of consumer
feedback mine included they made the
apple logo much lighter the first
version of this when they first came out
the apple logo was actually white so it
was just a nice little outline which was
really perfect i wonder if they're gonna
do bumpers for the new phones
that's gonna be interesting to see if
they do
here's all the leather colors
not a big fan of the leather cases it's
really probably just a preference they
do get a little bit scratched i've found
they've got a lot more options for the
iphone 7 than the iphone 7 plus so
that's interesting probably because no
one was 100 sure if they were going to
have that dual camera it was almost
pretty much confirmed this looks cool i
don't think i want that this is
something that everyone is
really looking forward to this 3.5
millimeter headphone jack adapter so if
you really have no idea how this works
you plug this into your phone and you
plug your headphones into here
quite
simple i wish they quit pushing all
their beats paraphernalia in my face
let's get to amazon now bose wireless
headphones let's see what they've got
i've yet to try these but i did just get
a pair of they're their purple sport
version and of course it does have
the 3.5 millimeter jack mostly because i
needed something to keep at my desk so
whenever i'm working i love using these
they're pretty much my favorite the bose
soundsport wireless headphones in black
and aqua here's a nice alternative to
beats by dre beats by
no so here's the problem with these for
me personally these don't work that well
in my ears i'm trying to see if i can
show you the difference here so these
ones don't have that little kind of nub
sort of thing maybe my ears are weird
i'm not sure
i know a lot of you guys i've seen it in
the comments that you also have trouble
with headphones so these ones don't
really work as well
at least for me personally but the best
part about this is you can get
replacement ones so
i'm using my webcam and this doesn't
this isn't really high quality
but if you can see this is the one that
i'm showing you on the screen just the
one on the screen is in black and these
are one of the replacement ones that you
can get so it's a different type of mold
these are like two dollars on amazon as
a replacement and they come with three
different sizes so you can always save
those if you need a backup so these i
actually haven't tried yet but i
would imagine if they are just as good
as these guys
then i definitely recommend it let me
know if you guys have any
recommendations that i should either try
or you have any recommendations for
anybody else watching this video leave
those comments below six hours of
battery per charge these ones are an
extra hour more
than the apple version of the air pods i
do like that these have a wire on them
because at least
i won't just lose one if i lose them i
lose both i'd rather lose both than just
lose one because then it's like
what do i do with this here's some of
the quiet comfort headphones up these
ones are the over-the-ear version
iphone 7
accessories let's see what kind of crazy
stuff they have on amazon super slim and
lightweight crystal clear protective
cover this is all
look at this bluetooth headset what is
this the heck
is this
it's 19.
it looks really classy
great color options
foldable bluetooth keyboard
this is definitely something that's
necessary
i definitely need this can you imagine
what crazy person i'd look like i'm like
oh hold on i'm on the airplane i unfold
my keyboard so that i can start texting
it's actually kind of a cool idea
even though it's just
it seems very silly
i'll get it this is a cool car mount
what's this thing what a cool idea
god i love the internet
two angles same comfort
won't stick to leather dashboards
ever wanted your car mounts to look as
great as your car
the stealth car mount has style and
character that's easy to use
this is so silly
i'm a little disappointed with all the
things on amazon because i thought we
were going to get like some crazy and
cool and wild things there's really not
much at all i'll put a link in the
description of some of the items that i
mentioned here if you guys are
interested in checking those out i
really want to know from you guys though
what are your favorite things that you
have been using i'm pretty brand loyal
so i don't usually stray too far from
the things that i know that i really
like so if you guys have any suggestions
that are really really cool i'd much
rather take your suggestions then just
kind of
try something at random and then it
sucks i'll see you guys soon i hope you
guys are all having a wonderful day and
i'll see in the next video let me know
if there's any videos that you'd like to
see me make about the iphone or anything
in general and i'll see you guys soon
bye
i agree
hurry up i need to go shopping i have to
go to the mall